- La contre-offensive
ukrainienne maintient
une pression constante
sur la ligne de front
dansrérérégion de Kherson,
seule grande capitale du sud
dont la Russie s'est emparée
dès le début de la guerre.
Ce soldat ukrainien raconte que
son unité combat deux à trois
fois par jour, en tirant toutes
les munitions dont elle ososose.
Aujourd'hui, Moscou a fait
marche arrière.
Le général Sergueï Sourovikine,
nommé il y a à peine un mois
à la têeseses troupes russes
après la débâcle de Kharkiv,
a exposé la situation
dans Kherson et a proposé que
l'armée se cantonne sur la rive
gaucu u u fleuve Dniepr.
Le retrait est ordonné
par le ministre de la Défense,
Sergueï Choïgou.
GASTON CÔTÉ, brigadier-général
à la retraite
- Sur le plan tactique, ce qui
était un avantage stratégique
d'avoir cette capitale-là,
maintenant ne fait plus de sens.
On sait qu'ils ont eu énormément
de difficultés à faire des
franchissements d'obstacles,
surtout sur la rivière Dnipro.
Chaque fois, ils ont été
réellement réduits en misss
lors de leurs tentatives
de franchissement d'obstacles.
- Un repli que le président
ukrainien Zelensky prend
avec beaucoup de prudence. Dansn
sur sa chaîne "Telegram"
il ajoute que l'ennemi
ne leur fait pas de cadeau
et ne manifeste pas de geste
de bonne volonté.
Les Russes ont expliqué
leur retranchement par
un problème de ravitaillement.
- Le système de ravitaillement
est encore fait pour
une campagne éclair,
alors que, présentement,
ils ont été incapables
réellement de se concentrer
dans un seul secteur qui
a besoin réellement d'être
réapprovisionné quotidiennement.
(tirs)
- Le soutien logistique et
en matière de renseignements
des États-Unis et de l'OTAN
rendent l'offensive russe
laborieuse.
"Si le président Poutine
gagne en Ukraine, ce sera
désastreux pour les Ukrainiens
et nous rendrait également
plus vulnérables."
Si la victoire de l'Ukraine
à Kherson se confirme,
elle portera un coup dur
à la Russie qui avait annoncé
en grande pompe l'annexion
de la région il y a
à peine quelques semaines.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.